the irs must hand over donald trump's
taxes says a judge
at this point this is more of a ha ha
thing than substantively meaningful if
and until donald trump declares that he
is again a candidate for the republican
nomination in 2024 but this is something
that's been going on for so long think
back to the primary period
in 2016 when donald trump was asked
people with tears in their eyes saying
sir where are your taxes and donald
trump said i'm under audit
once there's no more audit i will
release my tax returns and of course it
never made sense why didn't it make
sense well
he obviously wasn't under audit for
every year
why didn't he release the taxes for the
years not under audit because it was all
a lie all along
and a house committee investigating
malfeasance and wrongdoing and
subterfuge
has been trying to obtain donald trump's
taxes for years at this point
this is supposedly the absolute
final definitive
last step
rolling stone reporting irs must hand
trump's tax returns over to the house
committee according to a court judge
david sintel wrote tuesday the chairman
has identified a legitimate legislative
purpose that it requires information to
accomplish oh i don't have this article
here i guess i have to subscribe to
rolling stone uh but i can tell you what
the determination is
one of the things that's at issue
when a judge is to determine a question
like
does the irs have to give tax returns to
a house committee
is is there a valid
legitimate
substantive reason
legislatively
for the house committee to have these
taxes if a court believes or determines
that the reason that the house wants
trump or anyone else's tax returns from
the irs
is uh out of curiosity a fishing
expedition to make someone look bad or
for whatever any other reason other than
a legislatively substantive reason
they would say the irs does not have to
turn these documents over
what the court found
is that there is legitimate and
substantive justification
for the house of representatives uh
committee to have those tax returns so
trump is having a really really bad week
i don't know at this point
what would come from a public standpoint
from donald trump's taxes being given to
this house committee but consider
that if he does run again
he is of course going to try to shield
his taxes again i mean listen the guy
won without ever publishing his taxes
which is something no other presidential
candidate has been able to do
and so i'm still interested in seeing
what's there i think that all of the
things we expected would be there
trump's not as wealthy as he claims to
be trump plays very fast and loose with
the values of many of his assets all of
these different things
um and what impact they would have on
trump voters at this point is probably
almost zero but what a week a photo
surfaced showing trump flushing
documents down toilets mar-a-lago is
rated he has to be deposed by letitia
james and now his taxes are going to the
house committee not a particularly good
week